so
an accountant broke down remember when
we did this tax situation comparing
and the main thing we talked about was
what we talked mainly about
capital gains right hey 39.6 versus
you know 23 and and then you said well
who cares if i'm not selling the company
i don't care if i'm selling the company
or not now i said you know that's a very
good point
why don't we look at all the different
areas of what's going to happen with
taxes
so this organization what they did is
they waited they looked at both
tax plans trumps and bidens and they
compared
every area of tax whether it's corporate
tax whether it's
you know income tax whether it's a
capital gains tax
and you'll be able to see how they're
both going to be uh in place
whoever you vote for so tax policies are
hot potentially in the most part there's
presidential elections even the current
health pandemic and social unrest
i believe that the trump biden contest
will ultimately turn towards taxes
we now have data on just what democrat
joe biden proposed entails
let's compare president donald trump's
federal tax rate and biden's proposed
rates to see how wide the disparities
are keep in mind these figures
are for the highest so maximum tax
bracket for each of the four categories
which you
ultimately pay is your effective tax
rate a blend of the different tax
brackets very important for people to
know that that they're shown
worst case scenario here's what you're
facing but you're going to be in the
ultimate tax bracket so let's go to the
next one here
what is it atlanta journal constitution
i'm pretty sure yeah so so here's what
you're looking at
here's what you go go look at let's look
at one by one
corporate taxes trump is promote
proposing 21 which
is where we are right now biden wants
28. okay
by the way 28 would be the highest in
the world for corporate sales tax we
would have the highest we're number one
we would be number one if biden's 28
percent was it under obama
uh i want to say uh uh even maybe a
little higher than that
obama 35 is what i remember uh but we'll
check that here in a minute
income and payroll taxes trump's 37
biden's top line is going to hit 52.
small business taxes trump's 29.6
bidens is 39.6 capital gains we already
know 23.8
versus 43.4 so here's the thing
when they say taxes are
only going to affect the rich there is
no way
in the world right taxes are only
affecting the rich
oh god no so so yesterday he said on the
town hall i don't know if you caught
that
when george asked biden which george
didn't really push the
concept too much but george asked biden
saying don't you think with the way the
economy is right now this is not a good
time to raise taxes like don't you think
we shouldn't be doing it right now we
should wait a little bit
before we raise taxes it's like well and
he kind of you know didn't really give
full
an answer but this is what you're
looking at if you're watching this right
now what are you thinking with these tax
rates knowing this is where we're going
when
we vote trump or biden i think
i think biden is going to wait i think
he'll wait till the second
hour of his presidency before he starts
raising taxes and get rid of everything
that trump did
this is criminal right here 52 how could
you ever propose
over 50 of what you make you have to
give away
and that's a starting point okay that's
that's where they start they go north
from there
and the other thing pat is at the very
beginning of this this expert you know
that did this report
he said ultimately i think taxes are
going to decide the election
good trump wins i hope he's right
period tell me how you really feel tom
tell me how you really feel i don't know
how do you feel yeah let me ask you
you're saying that anything over 52
is criminal criminal criminal never it's
certainly wrong
unethical when's the last time taxes
were that high
god i don't know i wasn't ready for a
quiz i don't know when do you think it
was last time a democrat
has it ever been that high oh is this a
stumper is this a reply i'm asking
you're saying it's criminal are you
asking because you know the answer i'm
just saying
taxes as we've discussed on the podcast
we're way north of that for the one
percent for many
many many decades so look just before
everyone goes on the attack mode
do i want to pay more taxes hell no do i
want more corporations to pay higher
taxes
hell no but let's not act like there
isn't precedent for higher taxes it's
not good
that's not the question though the
question is you have two choices when it
comes down to strictly taxes this is a
logical conversation not an emotional
one
totally if you don't look at the names
and we don't call it joe biden or we
don't call it trump moving forward in
2020
elections are not about human beings
that can go out there and be empathetic
or get out there and say get him out of
here forget about names right
forget about faces it's purely policies
okay
you got these two policies by the way
it's not even democrat republican take
all that names out totally
think out you got these two policies
which one are you voting for
there's 100 chance i'm voting for the
lower tax okay
but give us the butt there's no but okay
so but that's not the only issue on the
ballot
but what were you saying if taxes are
the only issue on the ballot if that's
like
listen do you go to the polls to for
taxes then yes then i'm
straight up going let me ask you a
question what is the one thing
that is going to affect a hundred
percent of people
taxes is is pro-life pro-choice going to
affect 100 percent of people
no is nra going to a second amendment
going to affect 100 of people
we hope so but no it's not no climate
change
climate change is not 100 of people
right it's opinion
but it's opinious this is also this
guy's opinion though no it's no no
that's what it says at the top of the
piece
this inion this is this is a plan that
was proposed to them and they looked at
this is not his opinion
these numbers are not his opinion
correct but this article is no i'm i'm
not looking at the article i'm looking
at the numbers
the numbers are not in the paper i want
to pay low tax but i think we all do
what i'm trying to ask you and the
viewers that are listening to this
is we have to we have to get to the
following number and
and look at it from this standpoint for
example last night we were here till one
o'clock in the morning yeah can i give
you a shout out yeah your team can we do
that can we deviate for two seconds
you were here till 1am crushing it yeah
you had your whole team here we had it
we had the whole you've got probably
four hours of sleep maybe i'm not i'm
i'm going on fuel you are i could tell
yes i am on how do you feel this morning
i want to know how you feel
i'm on i want to know how you feel you
want to talk about taxes yeah
we want to talk about taxes here's what
i'm trying to tell you last night
we uh uh this 3.5 million dollar project
that we've been working on for the last
two years two plus years right
we finally launched it this monday okay
we had to migrate
we turned off all our systems last
saturday 8 00 p.m and we turn it back on
on monday at 8 a.m right so it's 36
hours we're off
and we're migrating that's a few hundred
thousand clients that are going from one
system to another system
lots of security things that we're doing
all this other stuff right last night
we're sitting here in a room and uh
the the thing with a new software is
nothing's gonna always be perfect i
prepared everybody i said listen there's
gonna be glitches
there's gonna be bugs i've been saying
this for two months i don't want any
complaining
we're gonna get through this we simply
want you to tell us what bugs you find
so great we're having a meeting last
night at around five six o'clock and
they're saying here's what
we want you to know this is what we're
expecting i said i said all i care about
is the following i said don't tell me
about the problems we can't solve i'm
only focused on problems we can solve
today right
and because we need customer service
we're gonna have four different zooms
we'll create
one zoom is for anybody to jump in that
has any question
from that zoom you go to three specific
zooms that's niche to what you want
whether you're submitting a business or
it's licensing or whatever right okay
so we went on people got on hey this is
you should go here go here go here
here's the point we made a decision to
do something
that a hundred percent of people were
affected by not
just one audience it was an issue that
we made here's what we're gonna do this
is what everybody's affecting
everybody's being affected by
this area of this business and that's
what i'm gonna i'm not focused about the
five percent
not the eighteen percent not the forty
two percent what's a hundred percent the
hundred percent was the software
they have an issue on it right uh the
one area out of all of these issues
these political people are bringing up
whether it's trump biden both sides left
right
cnn msnbc fox the one thing that affects
all of us is taxes
and those are the numbers so if you say
if you're telling me that's the number
one issue
it is the number one issue because it's
the one thing that we're all affected by
and the election always comes down to
the economy for the most part it always
comes down to numbers and that's the
other thing that
when you think of how warped this
country is right now how whacked and
just
out of touch and just how messed up we
are i mean
media people like to make money they
like to keep their money
they like to kind of can you pull back
the taxes yeah you took it away and the
fact that they are just
hammering this to the point i mean
they're going to be affected like you
said 100 percent
by the way you go for biden you also get
the added bonus of
crime antifa you know higher state
income taxes too
but but you know what crime antifa let's
say that
i'll set that aside because what i do
know is the following
any time i was tempted to do something
stupid was when i was broke
okay any time i was tempted to do
something stupid i was broke even the
thought crossed in your mind
right the more people make money the
lower the crime
the better the economy the better people
do the less they think about even doing
any kind of riots or robin or stealing
or anything
if somebody's making money they don't
have any crazy thoughts
my dad told me a long time ago he says
listen man
has to make money when the man of the
household doesn't make money
he does stupid things he has to feel
like he's providing
if we get more people that feel like
they're providing
we have less issues those taxes get more
people to make money you're going to say
something oh no yeah
people become desperate when they don't
make money bad decisions and you
compound that by
tens of thousands and then a million
people and you get a real problem in
your country